protesters in Russia are demonstrating
against what they say will be a rigged
election in March thousands gathered
yesterday in dozens of Russian cities
they're upset President Vladimir Putin
is all but assured victory Elizabeth
Palmer is in Moscow where Putin's most
prominent critic was arrested minutes
into the protest Elizabeth good morning
the demonstration was called for
mid-afternoon on a freezing Moscow day
but even so the organizers say that the
crowd ended up being about 2,000 strong
just minutes after Alexei Navalny showed
up in his demo the police moved in and
arrested him on grounds that he hadn't
got the right permit
meanwhile thousands of his followers in
Moscow and across Russia were already on
the streets and yet were facing in which
he's going to win another six-year term
among the protesters chants a current
favourite Putin is a thief
Navalny are high-profile anti-corruption
activists is the only political figure
who could have posed a serious challenge
to Vladimir Putin in the March election
but the Kremlin has fixed that he's
barred from running but that's not going
to change the result everybody is
already sure who's going to win
now today the Kremlin's attention is
fixed on Washington because it's widely
expected that the US Treasury is going
to publish a list so-called oligarchs
list of people wealthy people
influential people close to Putin the
inner circle and maybe even their net
worth which could be very embarrassing
already officials are saying that this
is America meddling in Russia's election
scale right it's an interesting turn
thank you very much Elizabeth Palmer in
Moscow